in this video I will be using Venn
diagrams to give a graphical
representation of the set operators we
learned in the previous video so if you
recall the definition of a union B you
know that a union B equals the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a or X is an element of B so
if we let this circle represent the set
a and we let this circle represent the
set B then that means that X can land
anywhere in any of these circles which
is why this red the entire region is
shaded red we're saying that this red
region represents all possible values of
X and if we recall the definition of a
of a intersection B that equals the set
containing elements X such that X is an
element of a and X is an element of B
which is why the overlap where a B
overlap is is shaded red we're saying
all possible values of X are this red
region now the set difference of a and B
equals the set containing elements X
such that X is an element of a and X is
also not an element of B which is why
it's just this region here none of the
elements are within B the set difference
of B and a is the set containing
elements X such that X is an element of
B and X is not an element of a and
finally the symmetric difference of a
and B I defined as the union of a minus
B and B minus a so we take this region
in this region and we take the union of
it which is why this is the resulting
region there's no overlap between the
two now this is a really good way to
familiarize yourself with the concept of
set operators however don't rely on it
you should really focus on the
definitions as it will help you out in
the long term